did you catch that unscripted scarlet
witch moment in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness keep watching to
find out what went down on set and why
elizabeth olsen said she did not enjoy
it at all olsen scarlet witch has
entered a bit of a dark phase in her mcu
character arc after losing vision to the
infinity war capping struggle against
thanos and the grueling meditation on
grief that was one division she has
achieved full villain status in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness in
some sense this iteration is a return to
form for the sokovian witch as longtime
fans will surely remember she began her
mcu journey as a dangerous hydra
experiment in the mid credits scene in
captain america the winter soldier that
version of wanda had completed a full
redemption arc by the time infinity war
rolled around but after the collapse of
her idyllic hex around westview new
jersey she's arguably more dangerous
than ever before so it's perhaps
unsurprising that the actress behind
scarlet witch had trouble filming some
of her darker scenes in horror maestro
sam raimi's doctor strange sequel for
olson the issue was organic to the
script and things got the darkest when
she was working with two of her youngest
co-stars as the old saying goes every
villain thinks they're the hero of their
own story the same is true for wanda as
she goes down her dark path in the film
with her scarlet witch powers waxing she
becomes obsessed with seeing her family
again but once she crosses over into
earth 838 reunites with them and gets
pelted in the face for her trouble she
starts screaming an angry mom voice at
her boys according to a recent interview
with variety olson admits that while
filming she got smacked in the face
really hard with a prop that the child
actors opposite her and the scene were
throwing it wasn't planned but the
ensuing reaction that injury drew out of
olsen made the scene all the more
intense olsen told variety one of the
people that i love the little people
that i love they were throwing things at
me in the scene and accidentally smacked
my face really hard and that was the
best reaction and i felt so bad that i
used it as the actor and let it inform
how i responded to these people that i
love because they were terrified after
it really was something i did not enjoy
at all but i knew it'd be good for the
scene for any actor playing a character
like wanda maximoff is a major challenge
because of all the twists and turns in
her story before doctor strange 2 olsen
had already taken wanda through one
entire redemption arc coming on the
heels of wand division wanda is back in
full blown villain mode for olson some
of wanda's actions in doctor strange 2
are disturbing and she had a difficult
time reconciling them with the character
she thought she knew in the film wanda
is determined to create a universe where
her two boys exist but this comes at the
cost of having to destroy america chavez
a teenage girl with the ability to
travel through multiverses we found a
girl who can somehow travel across it
but she's being pursued received by him
some kind of demon one of the covets her
power for itself not only is wanda
willing to send demons after a teenager
but when dr strange and his fellow
wizards try to stop her things get
violent wanda wipes out several of
doctor strange's fellow wizards plus an
entire superhero team called the
illuminati which includes alternate
earth versions of dr charles xavier and
captain carter olsen was troubled when
she found out her character was willing
to eliminate anyone who got in her way
in order to deliver her performance she
had to get into the right mindset olson
explained to variety i just had to
buckle down and think all these people
are in her way and she's warned doctor
strange not to get in her way and he did
he didn't listen and so i just had to go
from that point of view wanda's heel
turn might be familiar to comics readers
but it's still unsettling especially for
olsen check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]